[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your data about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Behind AlphaGo Is
Google DeepMind.
Their mission is to solve
intelligence and use it to make
the world a better place.
And they've decided to
start using TensorFlow
for all their future research.
They believe it will
enable them to execute
their ambitious research
goals at much larger scale
and an even faster pace.
For more details and to join
the discussion, click the link.
The latest version
of Android Studio
now supports Android and
developer preview along
with improvements
to Instant Run that
let you update incremental
changes to your app
code significantly faster.
Follow the link for
details and the update.
Starting with Android
N, there is a new mode
called Direct Boot, which is
when the device is powered on,
but the user hasn't
yet unlocked it.
It's ideal for apps that
schedule alarms, provide
important and
timely notifications
such as messaging apps,
or provide services
to other apps or the system,
such as accessibility services.
If your app is similar
to one of those,
check out the post on how
to support Direct Boot.
According to a study by Juniper
Research, barely 1% of apps
are now paid for at
the point of download.
With this demand for
free apps on the rise,
you're left with an
important question.
What's the best way
to publish your app
for free while sustainably
funding your business?
Well, here's the no nonsense
guide to in-app ads.
In it you'll learn foundational
advertising concepts,
how pay per click works, a
basic explanation of ad networks
and how they can help you
monetize your app, and more.
Click the link to grab the
ebook and get started today.
In addition to the credential
management API mentioned
last week, Chrome 51 beta
also reduces the overhead
of offscreen rendering.
For more details
on these updates,
as well as all the new features
and changes in this release,
check out the post.
It's time to say
goodbye to OAuth 1.0.
Goodbye.
So long.
We are moving away from
the OAuth 1.0 protocol
in order to focus our
support on the current OAuth
standard, OAuth 2.0, which
increases security and reduces
complexity for developers.
This final phase of the shutdown
will see two legged OAuth 1.0
go away on October 20, 2016.
For more information and
tips on moving to OAuth 2.0,
take a look at the post.
In fact, take a look
at all the posts.
They're super.
Like, subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]